Гамбург завжди у русі.
Мільйони людей щодня пересуваються мільйонами маршрутів.
Аби місто функціонувало злагоджено,
німці інвестують у новітні цифрові рішення.
Приміром, це програмне забезпечення
допомагає краще координувати дорожньо-будівельні проекти.
Завдяки йому тепер можна одразу побачити,
що і де саме планують ремонтувати або будувати.
Якщо виникають якісь накладки,
певні проекти можна перенести на інший час або ж регулювати таким чином,
щоб виникало якомога менше заторів.
Це аж ніяк не єдине ноу-хау в Гамбурзі.
Світлофори тут також об'єднані в мережу.
Приміром, подається сигнал,
аби світлофор з наближенням автобуса сам перемикався на зелене світло.
А для звичайних автівок програмне забезпечення управляє світлофорами із урахуванням часу пік.
Звичайно, вранці значно більше автомобілів та мотоциклів їдуть в місто, аніж з міста.
Тож світлофори програмуються таким чином, щоб оптимізувати дорожній рух в місто.
У царині цифрової мобільності серед німецьких міст Гамбург уже нині передовик.
У 2021-му році місто прийматиме Міжнародну конференцію інтелектуальних транспортних систем.
Мета - аби до того часу мешканці міста
ще менше стояли у заторах.
Дуже важливо, щоб  автомобіль та світлофор "комунікували" між собою.
Щоб водій отримував сигнал, коли світлофор зміниться на зелений, і щоб він розумів,
як йому оптимально підїжджати до перехрестя, щоб не довелося гальмувати і знову рушати.
Швидко доїхати і гарантовано без заторів - це можливо на метро або потязі.
Ті, хто не має станції прямо поруч з будинком, можуть залишити свої автівки на парковці
поруч із зупинкою і далі їхати громадським транспортом.
Метро пов'язане з мережею "кар-шерінг" - сервісів колективного користування автівками.
Існує мобільний додаток, який показує всі варіанти руху громадського транспорту в Гамбурзі.
Він також показує, де найближча "кар-шерінг" станція, де поруч станція метро,
куди під'їжджає трамвай, і як дістатися від точки А в точку Б.
У майбутньому ми хочемо створити єдину онлайн-платформу, на якій можна було б не тільки побачити всі варіанти,
але й реєструватися та сплачувати за проїзд.
Викликом для міст-мільйонників є не лише транспорт, але й співіснування мешканців.
В гамбурзькому університеті HafenCity допомають розробити цифрову модель міста.
Наприклад, вони вираховують, де люди найохочіше проводять час та чому.
Спершу ми повинні дослідити, як взагалі функціонують ті чи інші місця:
наприклад, як поводять себе людей, які приходять погуляти з собаками,
як вони роблять закупи, чи затримуються там на певний час.
Щоб у цілому зрозуміти, як функціонує той чи інший простір і як зробити так,
щоб люди проводити там побільше часу.
А ті, хто тільки планує в місті будівництво, можуть задати в компютерну програму
свої проектні критерії та порівняти, де краще будувати, приміром, дослідницький інститут:
під боком чи там, де можна швидко доїхати до аеропорту?
Гамбуржці переконані: новітні технології дають можливість
створити більш приємне співіснування людей у містах-мільйонниках.